[Musique]
depuis quelques années la télémétrie est
indissociable de la compétition thomas
lui et le responsable d'une brigade
d'informaticiens des supers blick
mais surtout des ingénieurs canalise en
temps réel la fiabilité la stratégie de
course la performance plus ici le
pilotage
thomas est le seul à parler constamment
à celui qui est seul dans la voiture
depuis je fais ce travail là je n'ai
jamais vu la voiture se déplacer car la
voiture la paroisse de démarrer moteur
tant que je suis pas derrière les écrans
a vérifié par m donc je n'ai jamais vu
la voiture se déplacer pour lui le
pilote presque si tu parles pas de tour
il appelle à mais vous êtes là et c'est
vraiment important
aujourd'hui il faut le dire je pensais
pas le ressentir à ce point là quand le
pilote monte je monte à la vie à
l'intérieur des centaines de capteurs
actifs mais au fond du stand comme au
bureau toute information est étudiée on
a la position des voitures on a
évidemment le signal télé on se fixe ce
qui se passe dans la course grand tout
ça ça fait quatorze écrans en tout on
est quatre ingénieurs pour gérer tout ça
et toute information on les traite pour
savoir ce qui se passe savoir ce qui
s'est passé et savoir ce qu'on va faire
il n'y a pas de ceux qui montent n'est
pas fiché mais on l'a dans les infos
c'est un travail d'équipé pendant la
course et en dehors
analyse est constamment analysé frein
moteur suspension trajectoire freinage
consommation pneumatiques et des
centaines d'informations pour
s'approcher du parfait mais parfois
c'est sans compter sur l'humain
la mesure entre le sport automobile et
la vie réelle elle est dingue et qu'on
en prend conscience et on prend vraiment
à chaque ce qu'aujourd'hui en sport auto
on parle en g
on parle en mm on parle en centaines de
pieds m eur et on parle en millions
d'euros gagné un dixième de seconde sur
la piste ça me coûte une énergie folle
par contre un mécanicien tribu dans les
stands et on perd 20 secondes de
trébucher dans la vie c'est dingue et du
coup le lien entre gagner un dixième de
seconde sur la piste et perdent 20
secondes pour un truc qui se passe alex
c'est incroyable conclusion l'excellence
technique n'exclut pas l'émotion des
hommes de löw
que l'on perde ou que l'on gagne
[Musique]